THE STATE OF MOBILE GAMING:
Remember 5 to 10 years ago when everyone used to
play mobile games. You had cult like friend groups
that swore by Clash of Clans or Clash Royale or
Geometry Dash. They would spend all of their
allowed iPad time or iPod time on these games
and that’s all they would talk about at school and
at hangouts and basically anywhere else they met
up. Don’t ask me how I know. And those were just
the tier 1 games, you also had a slew of tier 2
games that were sometimes even more popular. These
games didn’t have as dedicated fan bases though.
They were more of something that you would play on
the bus or at lunch or whenever you had a bit of
free time. I’m talking about games like Temple
Run, Subway Surfers, Flappy Bird, Crossy Road,
2048, Andry Birds, and so much more that I can’t
even remember because those days are unfortunately
long gone. At first, it seemed like it was just
these OG games that were dying out as they had
simply run their course. But, the more time that
passed, the more it became clear that mobile games
in general were falling out of favor. Of course,
we’ve seen newer games like Among Us and Fall
Guys clones have their 5 seconds of fame but none
of these games have had the same sticking power
as the OG games. Here’s how the interest graph
looks for Among Us for example. As you can see,
it was just one massive spike. For perspective,
here’s how the interest graph for Clash of Clans
looks like. It’s much more of a mountain of
interest the lasted multiple years than just a
singular spike that lasted months. Now, I do want
to note that Geometry Dash has making a comeback
out of nowhere which I think is largely due to
extremely high quality videos made by people
like Samifying and MathGenius that have reminded
millions of OG players just how fun this game was.
But aside from this exception that we don’t even
know how long will last, mobile gaming is very
much a shell of its former self which is extremely
confusing given that smartphones have just become
even more popular throughout all of this. So, why
does no one want to play mobile games anymore?
THE GLORY DAYS:
To answer why no one plays mobiles games anymore,
we first have to take a look back at what made
mobile games so popular in the first place which
I think can be boiled down to 3 reasons starting
with the network effect. None of the games that I
played as a kid were something that I found on my
own on YouTube or the App Store or something. All
of the games that I played as a kid were games
that people around me played. People at school,
people on the bus, people at hangouts, and also
a few dads who wanted to be cool. Nowadays,
I never see anyone around me playing mobile
games. My only exposure to mobile gaming is
through ads from games like Raid Shadow Legends
which is obviously not as effective. This isn’t
to say that the network effect ever changed. The
number one reason that people download apps today
is also because of people around them. But,
what did change were the type of apps that
benefitted from the network effect. Nowadays,
it’s much more common for a social media app or
tv show to benefit from the network effect than a
mobile game. And that brings us into reason number
2 which is that mobile games used to have larger
than game goals. Take Clash of Clans for example.
Progressing in the game wasn’t just about personal
growth or something, it was much more competitive.
You wanted to be the first guy to get to town
hall 10 or 3000 trophies or beat hexagon force
in your friend group, and that was just on a micro
scale. The most successful games also had larger
macro goals. You wanted your friend group to
beat a rival friend group in a clan war or
your clan to have more champion league players or
whatever the case may be. Zooming out even more,
you wanted your favorite YouTuber to be the one
that won these massive YouTuber Clash of Clans and
Clash Royale tournaments. This competitive spirit
probably doesn’t seem like that big of a deal but
it made all the difference. Why you ask? Well,
because no game is always 100% fun. With any game,
there’s high points and low points. But, for these
games with larger than game goals, you didn’t just
quit when things got a bit slow or boring because
you still had larger than game goals. You still
had to beat that rival clan, you still had to get
to the legendary league, you still had to beat
Theory of Everything 2. And these macro goals
gave these games an insane amount of sticking
power. It wasn’t until entire communities got
bored of a game and its overarching goals that
they would actually die. Speaking of communites,
mobile games back in the day also benefitted from
massive YouTube promotions and I’m not talking
about paid promotions. I’m talking about dedicated
YouTube channels that covered these games. People
like Chief Pat, Galadon, Molt, Clash With Ash,
Orange Juice, BjCanDive, Flammy, and so many more.
Not only did these channels help these games grow
in popularity but more importantly, they helped
them stay relevant through ups and downs. This
sort of community is what has kept games like
Minecraft so popular over the years. But,
a lot of these channels nowadays don’t even
cover mobile gaming anymore or even post for
that matter. And we have yet to see a new wave
of YouTubers take their place. For example,
there is no such community for Among Us or
Fall Guys or some other new mobile game.
Combine this lack of community with very little
network effect and no larger than game goals,
and it’s no wonder why these games have
fallen out of popularity. But all of that
only tells half the story which brings
us into the developer side of things.
PREDATORY MONETIZATION:
One of the main reasons that
mobile gaming became so popular in the early 2010s
is because they were free to play. As long as you
had a smartphone or tablet, anyone could download
a mobile game and start playing. This isn’t to
say that developers didn’t make any money though.
If your game was super popular and you had super
enticing in game purchases like SuperCell, you
could also become super rich. But somewhere along
the line, monetization became more important than
the user experience and the enjoyability of the
game itself. At first, this was just something
that manifested in tier 2 games. You know,
those airplane mode games like Subway Surfers that
filled up time. Initially, the economics of these
games were simple. You usually had a lite version
of the game and a full version of the game. The
lite version of the game was usually free and
came with fewer levels and maybe some ads here
and there. The ads weren’t all that serious though
as developers weren’t really trying to make money
off of ads. Their number one goal with the lite
version was to convince people that the game was
actually fun and worth spending a dollar on to get
the full version, and the full version is where
they actually made their money. But all of this
changed with the rise of free to play tier 1 games
like Clash of Clans, Clash Royale, Pubg mobile,
Fortnite mobile, and so on. There was like a
direct inverse correlation between the popularity
of these games and people’s willingness to pay for
mobile games. If something as built out as Clash
of Clans could be free, why did they have to pay
for these stupid tier 2 game. All of a sudden,
trying to convince free users to pay for the
full version of the game became magnitudes harder.
These developers had to pivot and figure out a way
to monetize free users and the easiest way to do
that is to just show a bunch of ads. And this is
what has led to the app store being filled with
thousands of games that are actually somewhat fun
but completely unenjoyable because you see an ad
every 30 seconds. As such, one of the main reasons
that mobile gaming has plummeted is because of
corporate efforts to monetize and restrict these
games. In the same manner, big banks have long
restricted our saving account interest rates. Of
course, the federal funds rate itself was low but
if we’re being honest, the 0.1 or 0.25% rates that
banks like Chase and Wells Fargo offered were
just downright disrespectful. The only reason
they kept it so low was because they knew that we
would keep our money with them anyway because of
the stability and security they offered. We wanted
to challenge this notion and that’s why we created
our own investing platform: Silo. Instead of
betting on the stability of Chase or Wells Fargo,
with Silo, you can bet on the stability of the US
federal government itself. You see, just like all
of us, the US federal government also needs to
sometimes borrow money. And if you’re willing to
write the US government a check, well, they’ll
currently pay you back with over 5% interest.
While all of us peasants were earning 0% interest
at Chase, this is where all of the biggest
corporations and investors were storing all
their cash. If you’d also like to take advantage
of treasury and bonds with the protection of
$500,000 in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million in
FDIC insurance, please consider checking out Silo
in the description below. But anyway, it wasn’t
just tier 2 games that made this transition. Tier
1 games would also make this transition. Tier 1
games didn’t plague their games with a bunch
of ads but what they did do was make the game
worse and worse for free players. Now of course,
these games were always easier to progress in if
you spent money but it was also realistic for a
free player advance and do well in the game. But,
in the second half of the 2010s, this would all
change as these games essentially became pay to
win. Clash of Clans for example currently costs
$143,000 to max out. And a recent Clash Royale
update increased the cost to max out by over
$14,000 by itself. Back in the day, it didn’t
cost that much to max out the entirety of Clash
of Clans. And the worst part is that the stuff
that costs the most money doesn’t add anything to
game play or enjoyabilty. It actually has to do
with upgrading walls or getting cards from level
14 to level 15, things that add no value to the
game other than just making these companies more
money. These companies probably thought that they
were doing the right thing for the company as
revenue continued to go up but they were also
simultaneously alienating free players who over
time wanted nothing to do with mobile gaming.
THE X FACTOR:
We’ve clearly seen massive
changes within the mobile gaming space both on
the community side and on the developer side,
much of which has been to the detriment of
mobile gaming as a whole. But, while these
shifts explain a lot, I think theres actually
an X factor that we have yet to consider which
is shifting demographics. I would bet that most
of you guys watching this video are likely in
your early to late 20s and are reminiscing about
the good ol days of mobile gaming back in middle
school and high school. And that’s not surprising
given that the primary demographic that plays
mobiles games are teenagers. And that’s why it’s
important to consider just how different modern
teenagers are compared to 10 years ago. Back in
the day, smartphones were just starting to gain
steam meaning that most of us had to beg our
parents for a smartphone and when we finally
did get a smartphone it came with a bunch of
caveats. We may have only had a gigabyte of data,
our phones may have had parental controls enabled,
and maybe we weren’t allowed to use social media
apps like Instagram and SnapChat. I remember one
of my elementary school friends, his parents would
turn off the wifi at like 8 or 9 because there
was simply no need for internet at night. So,
if he wanted to use his phone after 8 or 9, all
he could do was play offline games like Geometry
Dash. Not everyone had the same restrictions but
the restrictions were widespread enough that one
of the only things that everyone could do with
their phones together was play family friendly
mobile games. But a lot has changed since then.
Nowadays, smartphone have become a necessity and
if you’re over the age of 12, you probably
have a smartphone. Parents have also become
a lot less strict when it comes to phone usage.
Not only do modern kids have less strict screen
time but they also have unrestricted access to the
internet and social media. This isn’t to say that
parents have become more irresponsible per se but
simply that there is no other choice. I mean like
what are you gonna do, just shelter your kids
from the internet till their 18? First of all,
that’s just a massive disadvantage in the modern
age, and second of all, it’s not even possible as
kids are more tech savvy than ever and know how
to bypass any and every restriction. As such,
the focus has shifted from blocking what teenagers
have access to to teaching them how to be safe and
responsible on the internet. In other words, the
average teenager nowadays has access to social
media platforms like TikTok, YouTube, Instagram,
and Snapchat and that’s where they spend all of
their time. Aka, the casual teenage mobile gaming
market, the once largest market for these games,
has completely disappeared. And the teenagers
that are still interested in playing games
usually have console or PC for that leaving
modern mobile games in no man's land. It’s
really quite shame because playing these games
were some of my best childhood memories. But the
reality is that the mobile landscape has
massively shifted for gamers, developers,
and casual smartphone users and that’s why no one
plays mobile games anymore. If you would like to
help Silo not end up like that, please consider
checking out the link the description below.